HAS TO STOP AND PARENTS HAVE TO
GET INVOLVED.
DR. HAMILTON, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT, IT’S VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND AFTER HIS RECKLESS POLICIES
KILLED THOUSANDS OF NET NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS,
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO ACTUALLY
HAD THE GALL TO SAY THIS OF RED
STATE GOVERNORS.
>> I SAY TO THEM ALL LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS.
THE PLAY POLITICS WITH THIS
VIRUS AND YOU LOST.
IF YOU TOLD THE PEOPLE OF YOUR
STATE AND THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY, WHITE HOUSE, DON’T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
JUST OPEN UP AND GO ABOUT YOUR
BUSINESS, THIS IS ALL DEMOCRATIC
HYPERBOLE.
NOW YOU SEE 27 STATES WITH THE
NUMBERS GOING UP AND THEY WERE
IN DENIAL.
DENIAL IS NOT A LIFE STRATEGY.
>> Laura: NOW HE’S MOCKING
STATES LIKE FLORIDA AND TEXAS
WHICH DESPITE A RISE IN
INFECTIONS ARE NOT SEEN A SPIKE
IN DEATH.
TEXAS HAS ONLY EIGHT COVID DEATH
IN 100,000 PEOPLE, RANKING 43RD
OUT OF 30 STATES.
IN WASHINGTON SEE IN D.C. AND
NEW YORK, THEY HAVE 20 TIMES
MORE THAN TEXAS AND RANKING
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY.
HERE TO RESPOND, TEXAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK.
AS CASES ARISE, AND TEXAS IS
STEPPING ON THE BRAKES SO
SHOULDN’T THE ONES THAT WE LAID
OUT PROVIDE CONTEXT TO THIS
CONVERSATION OF INCREASING
INFECTION NUMBERS?
>> FIRST OF ALL GOVERNOR CUOMO
IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST FRAUD
WHO HOLD THAT POSITION IN THE
COUNTRY.
HE HAD ABOUT 6,000 PEOPLE DIE A
NURSING HOME AND WE HAD LESS
THAN A THOUSAND AND THAT’S ON
TOP OF THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED IN NEW YORK.
HE SHORTCHANGED THE PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK AND HE COST PEOPLE
THEIR LIVES AND HOW DARE HIM
COME ON AND POINT HIS FINGER AT
ANY OTHER GOVERNOR IN THE STATE.
AND WE ARE TESTING IN MORE THAN
OUR 254 COUNTIES AND WE WERE
BEFORE.
SO EXPECT THOSE NUMBERS TO GO
UP.
BUT HERE’S THE GOOD NEWS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE AREN’T
SEEING IT TRANSLATE TO THE ICU
UNIT OR INTO FATALITIES.
SO OVER THE LAST EIGHT DAYS WE
HAD 47, 29, 28, TEN, 17 PEOPLE
PASS.
EVERY LIFE IS VALUABLE BUT WITH
A SPIKE IN CASES AND A SPIKE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS, THE FIREWALL
SO FAR AS OF THE ICU UNITS.
I TALKED TO ONE MAJOR HOSPITAL
CHAIN LAST NIGHT AND IN MARCH
THEIR DEATH RATE COMPARED TO
POSITIVITY WAS ALMOST 4%.
MAY IT WAS 9% AND THIS MONTH
IT’S 5.9.
HERE’S A POINT.
NUMBERS ARE HIGH, BUT THERE IS A
LOT TO BE A VERY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED AND BEING
VERY CAREFUL BUT TO BE VERY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT BECAUSE THESE
ARE MOSTLY YOUNGER PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN HOSPITALS FOR HALF THE
TIME THEY WERE IN MARCH.
IT’S BEEN ALL OVER THE PLACE IN
TEXAS, WE HAVE 1400 WITH COVID.
721400.
>> Laura: AND YOU HAVEN’T EVEN
HAD TO MOVE ESSENTIAL SURGERIES
OFF OF THE TABLE.
YOU HAVE ROOM TO GROW IN YOUR
ICU AND I HOPE YOU DON’T HAVE TO
USE IT.
WE’LL TEXAS IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR
FORM, DAN PATRICK, SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE OF THE SPIKE?
>> GOVERNOR ABBOTT WAS VERY
CLEAR IN HIS ANNOUNCEMENT, WE
PUT A PAUSE ON ELECTIVE SURGERY
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE PLENTY OF
ROOM, BUT WE ARE NOT STEPPING
BACKWARDS.
OUR PAUSE BUTTON THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN, WE ARE ALREADY 75% OPEN,
PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE AND ABOUT.
IT’S ONE OF THE REASONS CASES
ARE OUT THERE WITH THE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
I’M GOING OUT AND THEY ARE
SOCIALIZING, WE WISH THEY WOULD
SOCIAL DISTANCE AS THEY DO THAT
BUT THAT’S BEEN THE BIG REASON
FOR THE SPIKE.
TO CLOSE THE LOOP ON THE ICU
CASES, WHEN THEY SAY IN TEXAS
IT’S 90 OR 95% FULL, THAT’S WITH
NONCOVID PATIENTS.
>> Laura: DAN, AND ABOUT THREE
OR 4 MINUTES, BECAUSE DAN HAS A
LONG HISTORY IN RADIO, TOO.
YOU CLARIFIED SO MUCH THAT HAS
BEEN CONFUSED, PURPOSELY
CONFUSED BY THE MEDIA.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS
TONIGHT.
WE WILL KEEP TRACK OF THIS
TONIGHT AND WE WILL CHECK BACK